we got there's there's big news oh good
big news and it's bad news for news
oh no oh are we are we news we're we're
a real accounts technically outskirt
news well this is entertainment this
entertainment this show is entertainment
oh good yeah alright bad news for news
industry they're collapsing hmm it is it
is flames man it is it is a the boat is
gone I have a feeling it's not the
mainstream media though no it is
oh this that's nuts oh those are all
different company Wow for those who are
just listening he were scrolling through
scrolling probably I don't know 100 more
than 200 different news companies and
this is not all of it I got more stories
check this out look at that Wall Street
Journal says this is from a few weeks
ago vice media document lays out plan
for layoffs amid coronavirus pandemic
planning document calls for over 300
layoffs though company says several such
proposals are being worked up Wow
it is flames all the way how many people
work advise I think a thousand wow
that's not entirely sure like 30% of the
company I might be it might be way more
than that because they've grown it's
been a long time since I've been there
okay
but yeah the media has gone up in flames
man yeah I got a bunch so vice is
denying this by the way they're pushing
back but but the Wall Street Journal did
include that saying that the you know
they're saying hey is just being worked
up but we've also got what is this one
BuzzFeed and Conde Nast are making more
cuts after pay reductions aren't enough
now here's the crazy thing I did a
segment earlier BuzzFeed just shut down
news operations for two offices yeah
this might be what they're talking about
hmm but I think these companies were in
trouble
a long time ago yeah you know now now
apparently according to conversation
they say nine reasons you should be
worried about the closure of BuzzFeed
news in Australia I'm sorry
death that's a jolly laughs hilarious
nine reasons too many
quartz has leg people off we got the
story digital media clobbered by
coronavirus it's just uh just clobbered
yeah yep mm-hmm this is a huge list so
really is you know before we get into
gloating over the demise of a lot of
these companies the first thing I'll
point out I'm only gloating at a few of
them right for the record that's true
good point yeah we only want to gloat
for a few and check us out so a lot of
these are just local newspapers okay
it's kind of bad local newspapers are
all right yeah they do is they do an
alright job and most of them seem to be
local papers and its local outlets that
are that are now suffering yeah so as
much as I want to laugh about
you know NBC Universal cutting executive
pay by 20 percent as if I care yeah
Univision layoffs furloughs and pay cuts
as if I care digital media oh this is
where it gets juicy BuzzFeed cut
employee pay cut a.m. to DM it's morning
news show eight people lost their jobs
and had furloughs of some staff now part
of me wants to say I'm sorry to these
individuals who lost their jobs okay but
these outlets are just so awful
yeah and they put out garbage fake news
look man we can complain about BuzzFeed
being biased yeah and that's when they
put out biased articles like if they if
they write something on the culture war
or politics it's really bad yeah but
BuzzFeed wrote a story about two black
men fighting to the death over fried
chicken which never happened oh yeah
that was and that was just like yeah it
was total BS in and it seems very
obvious that they were like oh this'll
get clicks yeah and they claim to be
like they write articles always in favor
of these lefty politics and ideas and
then when it wins their chance to write
some nonsensical rage bait that mocks
you know the black community and
stereotypes them oh they're the first
ones jump on board and I reached out of
them and I was like hey this is not true
here's proof they were like me okay they
sent me a link to like so the the
witnesses said there was no fight over a
chicken sandwich it was basically the
story was like two guys got into a fight
one guy got stabbed yeah and then
absolutely nothing to do with the
chicken sandwich well it did in the
sense that they were both in line they
were both had Popeyes and that's it and
that there you go and like that that's
Hot Buys though not the chicken sandwich
right what if they both didn't like
chicken engine
they were like everyday like Popeye
sagessa well they got fish it Popeye
yeah you never know
but the the gist of it was they BuzzFeed
said in the headline that it was a fight
over a chicken sandwich nobody had a
chicken sandwich
nobody had ordered one a dude cut in
line the other dude was like hey don't
cut in line and the guy was like F he
was like take it outside guy got stabbed
that was it yeah it was a fight over
cutting in line and the dudes family was
pissed because he was like he's like
ain't nobody died over a chicken
sandwiches BS to me he's lying yeah and
so I saw what BuzzFeed did and I'm like
dude that's not cool
and when I reached out to them the
response I got back was a quote from a
cop saying something like we think that
people were at Popeyes because of the
chicken sandwich right and I was like
that says nothing about these two men in
their fight right and that was it I
honestly when I first heard this story I
didn't think it was true I thought it
was a like a PR stunt from Popeyes
trying to sell the chicken sandwich I
think I joke I think you're right really
yeah I agree
like no one else so good are they spun
it no like I should use this yes so
where do the roads where did the
narrative emerge that these guys were
fighting over chicken sandwich right
I saw apparently like I think Popeyes
put out a statement uh-huh I could be
wrong and they're like we're so sorry
below blah the chickens I think they
were like lean into it we didn't mean to
make the chicken sandwich that good it's
like wait oh wait but in all seriousness
actually could you look this up I think
they'd to make a statement about it a
statement they man yeah and I think if I
was gonna make a bet I could be very
careful because you know we live in a
litigious country okay I'd be willing to
bet that their PR person heard the story
and was like do it do it pull the
trigger pull the trigger yeah no one
should fight over these chicken
sandwiches yeah it's not like they would
ever say that though in the statement no
they would say something like that like
it's it's terrible that you know at an
at the release of our new chicken
sandwich a fight broke out and something
like that you know I mean yeah I can't
remember exactly what happened with it
but I'd be willing about that's with a
narrative came from so when I look at
like BuzzFeed cutting employee pay
they're shutting down their Australian
news division and UK I I'm sorry man I'm
not I'm not gonna cry and Vox I know you
you're not oh look at this yeah where's
box
Vox furloughed more than 100 people for
three months you know what that's a good
amount of people
I seeing all this yeah I almost want to
cry tears of joy I you know because the
one way I have to explain what's going
on with with the digital media is that
it's like you had this gigantic machine
funded by venture capital okay and I am
but one person on YouTube desperately
trying to like fight back against all of
the lies and the smears and the fake
news and it's like trying to knock down
a skyscraper with a ball-peen hammer
you're just like you're going away at it
and then while you're doing it they're
building more yeah so it's like
ultimately just never get anything done
well you saw Shawshank right he escaped
with the you know took them away I try
to knock it down Bob you know it's the
same kind of thing you're so beaten at
the stone project I don't want these
people to lose their jobs Yeah right but
I do want the the whole system to be
reformed incredible and to get back
there's a really funny viral video going
around right now some dude I can't
member where he was I don't know some
local journalists was walking around a
protest its Long Island yeah we were
watching this video right and this guy
is being yelled at by Trump supporters
so like your fake news your fake news
and he's filming it and then it's like
such the it's the most pathetic like
mission-driven BS news reporting he's
like I'll never forget what happened to
me this day hounded and harassed and I
was just trying to tell their story yeah
man that was funny and they weren't even
being mean they were just kind of they
were just talked about calling him out
yeah it's funny because I've been at
protests where I've been physically
attacked and they're throwing explosives
and smoke bombs okay and the media
defended an tyfa they were like put
through food and fishes it's like yes
when they beat journalists they're
fighting fascists right great thanks
sure and so now that you're seeing
conservatives go you're fake news so
like oh oh oh no somebody is somebody
insulted me what do I do
oh my stars and there's there's where's
my group that support me right there's
an amazing amazing photograph of Jim
Acosta of CNN with this look on his face
like and there's someone flicking him
off like he's looking at like Oh like
how dare you Romo no Haram I work for
CNN I argue with Donald Trump you can't
be mean to me so here's I see this this
this guy right okay and he's claiming
that
you know oh I was always attacked and
berated in harass and I was simply
trying to tell their story and then he
adds a line where he's like these are
people who weren't even wearing masks
during a pandemic and I'm like in there
yep this guy came down and he was like
I'm just here to tell your story and
then he jumped the chance to be like oh
no they're attacking me and they won't
even wear masks like dude I can see what
you're doing man you're not there to
tell you that other story you were
looking for the conflict you know you
could play the victim and you know what
I know you want to be like Jim Acosta
but you'll never be you'll never be able
in the in the big leagues bro Jim Acosta
is like the Michael Jordan of fake news
yeah I'm almost offended that you you
would use Michael George that's not fair
I grew up in Chicago you did - how dare
you - but it was a testament to Michael
Jordan's greatness all right who's
someone infamous for doing something
awful but no Cosby Yuma Costas the Bill
Cosby of fake news why would you go
there I don't know okay so so no but
look Jim Acosta goes to these press
events with Trump and then he'll be like
he'll have like this big thing drawn up
where he'll start talking and then when
Trump is like thank you he'll keep
talking back next please
and he'll keep talking and you see this
with the other CNN reporters to where
they argue with the president you're
ridiculous like did you see that one
recently where that Chinese there's a
reporter she's from CBS but she is
Chinese yeah she asked Trump you know
like why are you trying to make a
competition Trump got offended like that
she asked you know it's a loaded
question it's like right it's like
asking you know when did you stop
beating your wife I was like why are you
treating us at competition it's like I'm
not but so Trump was like why don't you
ask China and then she goes and she
pulls her mask on he goes why did you
ask me that
let's like wait wait what what you're
pretending to be angry about this you
barely said that before I know it's like
you're talking about why I'm making it a
competition with China right that's what
the question was about the local
competition okay so I think Trump was
making a point when he said why don't
you ask China because China is lying
about their
right so his point was I'm not they're
the ones lying about their numbers let's
go ask them yeah but because she was
Chinese then brian Stelter I've seen and
is like it is racist
anyway I bring it up because the really
really good example of like asking a
loaded question that there's no real
answer to you know like what are you
supposed to say to get a reaction like
Adam when did you stop beating your wife
well I started shaving when I was 18
what what is that that's like that's
what they go to explenation what a load
the question is and so Trump gets mad
about it and then shaving is that is
that is that a are you making a
reference to like my lack of facial hair
for being Asian you're racist actually
and I argue with you yeah it's funny
like people tweet at me like to kid grow
beard I'm like yeah I know it's I mean
it's there I know you bigots I actually
I I did a little grooming today I say I
don't groom normally I'd get rid of it
but I was thinking maybe it made a girl
beard but it was like getting a little
long and annoying so her lip yeah I had
to get a little not the importance to
him a little bit there so anyway it's
like this guy who goes on a Long Island
at this Trump event or whatever it's
it's it's it's he was inspired you know
my Jim Acosta yeah but Jim Acosta man he
craved the sport it's like what you do
you go to the press briefing you insult
the president and then you argue with
him and then all of the resistance
people start wiggling their arms in
their keys yeah yeah yeah yeah that
video where the guys in the car and
there's all the turkeys in the pen and
he goes whoa and then all the turkeys
yell back and then he's have to look
both laughing so hard he's crying and
then he goes and then the turkeys all
gobble back that's what it is yeah so
like Jim Acosta is the dude in the car
gobbling and all of the resistance
anti-trump people are the turkeys
gobbling back yeah and it's like hey man
each each one of those gobbles he then
goes to advertisers and says hey man I
could make 100 turkeys gobble
you know how much gonna pay me and they
do and then he writes a book and then he
sells the turkeys books but you get you
get the reference you get the analogy so
this guy shows up tries pulling this off
and these journalists feign outrage like
what we were just trying to tell your
story oh then they're lying and this
will we get so let's take a look at some
of these these outlets that are getting
get
purged we got BuzzFeed VT digger a
non-profit digital news site in Vermont
first three layoffs I don't know they
are I'm not going to drag them Vice cut
some pay and and stopped 401 came
matching in promotions where's that name
matching so they said they stopped like
helping their employees into their 401k
contribution yeah so you if you yeah if
you put in money they'll put in Eagle
nuts a perk the outline laid off its
staff wait let up all of them goodbye
outline never heard of it is that little
never every single the outline an
attempt to build a bolder kind of news
website appears to have met its end wait
go back up go back up to the it's not
for everyone it's for you well they're
not employees yeah one one one audience
member isn't enough to sustain the
company sorry unless the one audience
member is Elon Musk and he's paying a
subscription yeah 100 thousand dollars a
month or something so what a shame what
else we have we have muscle digital
group laid off two dozen staffers Oh cry
me a river right
what is bustle they're like the ladies
thingy oh that's right that yeah that's
right what we got Elite daily inverse
Mike nylon the outline oh no oh no the
Zoe report you know I do what I do
without them I'm pretty sure all of
these people like they're mostly friends
with each other and I know this because
I worked for Vice I work for some of
these companies and they hang out with
each other and they're all probably like
sitting around complaining and smack
talking about us for for calling them
out like I'm sure yeah bring it on ji-ho
media which includes Jezebel that's been
the root and the onion late of 14
employees 14 Oh group nine seven percent
of its staff they they're the dodo
Thrillist and now this ooh now this by
the present no most of these now this is
fake news okay they create viral rage
bait for Facebook or they used to and it
would be like super loaded statements
and at VidCon several years ago the
president on stage said they had
partnered with anti-trump activists the
highest level for producing content or
something I filmed that I published it
as I was like wow that's a bold
statement for the president of a venture
capital backed news outlet to say
straight up
we are anti-trump activists they direct
our con
Wow so sad to see you go there the the
hill was implementing pay cuts now that
said he'll like that
yeah the hill is very good mocha yeah
the hell is very good Altice I 24 and
cheddar I don't care about them they're
fine they talk about you know pop
culture stuff or whatever Vox furloughed
more than 100 people for three months ah
yeah man I'm okay with protocol head
laughs I don't know them the skin
insider Louisville and curbed Atlanta
not sure who they are look curb Atlanta
said is a Vox media newsroom got him go
get them out a stop option for three
months it's evidence editor was
furloughed and and quartz they laid off
quartz laid off 80 people yeah yeah
quartz isn't that bad
no no I mean it's just digital digital
media yeah so let's see magazines we
have an update so apparently they keep
adding stuff Conde Nast Wow I have no
problem with that
that's huge I don't know what some of
these other things our time out I don't
care about that you know I'll be honest
man a lot of these a lot of these cuts
the kind of there are bombers you know
it's it's sad to see local news outlets
taking hits local papers aren't that bad
we need local journalism because when
you've got you know a town like you know
I don't know podunk or bumpkin Ville
okay yeah bumpkin Ville and I'm like a
fun place the bumpkin village is at or
bumpkin Ville bugle writes about the
mayor okay Lumpkin Ville yes the bumpkin
Ville bugle covers issues of like the
mayor and stuff and you're not gonna get
there from New York Times The New York
Times won't write about you know the
mayor of a town of a thousand you know
called bumpkin Ville yeah
but the bugle will so if you live there
it's important you learn about these
things so when local outlets are taking
hits and link people off that's when it
gets bad yeah one of the scariest things
that came up in the digital age you know
ten years ago was as easy as these
locals local outlets started going away
okay local corruption started going up
because if you've got a city councilman
or whatever who's stealing money a local
journalist would typically be like I'm
investigating this how I've uncovered it
yeah cops don't you know they're not
gonna investigate this the feds aren't
gonna come in it's the it's the public
access information gathering
intelligence but now that everyone's
drifting towards
you know hot like national international
level conversation in politics mm-hmm
nobody's covering local news anymore
except of the new coloca lout let's do
that's why it's sad to see them start
taking these sets yeah they're important
but one of the big problems is that one
of the reasons they're taking hits is
because they're being displaced by
BuzzFeed by Vox by having imposed
because these local outlets need to find
a way to become relevant and to make
money but traffic is essentially stolen
by bigger news outlets make sense it's
like you know especially if a certain
tube is pushing them on everybody yeah
talking about you to you you know I I
think I do think about how local
affiliates are really really bad at
using social media okay and why isn't
you know loke on local news Luke local
news outlet making a YouTube channel and
generating traffic and stuff like that
there is there is a challenge right if
you were in a town of a thousand people
you would make money by advertising
local services but now these people just
hire they buy the ads straight on Google
and Facebook you know so now Google and
Facebook are sucking all that money out
of these smaller towns and then the
local papers have no advertising you
know then they go under and who gets the
paper anymore
yeah I mean old people you have I think
it's funny too cuz like there's gonna
come a point where people are gonna be
arguing you know saying something
similar to us like you get your news
from the internet like and they're gonna
be getting it in some other way or
something maybe yeah
I don't know well I straight from there
neuro-link yeah they're no yeah they're
gonna have a feed constantly just
knowing everything I mean maybe in a
hundred years but I think we do get set
in our ways like every person does we
get used to the platforms we use young
people start using different platforms
and who knows what news is gonna be
alike could you imagine like tick tock
news no it's like Samaritans
yes I'm seventeen year old girl dancing
to like Tears for Fears while holding up
like a paper and it says like you know
trump impeach that's the news in the
future I don't know man I don't know who
knows oh it's gonna be loud that sounds
like she's from bumpkin bill yes sure
does no that sounds like that like you
when you look at a lot of these
companies and how they manipulated
facebook no no to get those those links
they didn't care about news that
actually matter they care about stories
that will get them out
shares right and so that's what drives
Facebook right now you know one thing I
see here go ahead give me the article
which one says NBC Universal is cutting
executive pay by 20% see like that why
aren't we seeing more of that all across
the board here like cutting executive
paid they don't they make way too much
money they don't want to cut their pay
dude I know yeah but there's a lot of
issues it couldn't it I mean we got we
got problems the lot gun as it is and
that's the next segment we're gonna be
talking about the lockdown is busted
yeah and we got we got some data for
that but look man people get a bailout
these big corporations you know golden
parachutes for the executives exactly
you know yeah we're safe everybody
everyone's get they're getting you know
gonna get an emergency paycheck but
after two weeks you're in trouble
Bob on the other hand we got a ten
million dollar bonus buddy and the
parachute is made of pure gold
how many falls to his death don't use
this by the way just to show off it's
just a sell later on yeah
don't actually try it you'll drop like a
rock it'll actually make you fall faster
speed things up well I won't actually
it's not how gravity works but you know
so I don't know man a lot of businesses
are going under and well I want to say
it's really bad now it is really bad
yeah it seems really bad no because even
though I don't like these people it's a
major disruption to the economy but I
wonder if there will be an improvement
because what what's you know I want to
equate some of these news outlets to a
thing that slowly starts growing and
absorbing nutrients and resources from
the body until it becomes a weighted
detriment I got us I got this cancer oh
I didn't say it yes I was just guessing
I was just guessing what you were
thinking these these these outside was I
right yeah yes these outlets are
siphoning away resources exploiting the
system producing garbage information
that's making people go insane and it's
in its it's a detriment on the minds the
psyche and the culture of our country my
next guest was tapeworm so you know what
you know you know I was thinking right
think about what's going on the economy
okay
and I mentioned this earlier I want to
might one of my opposite where my videos
it's like a it's like we were poisoned
and the poison the lockdown
is killing large portions of you know
the body but not totally killing the
body itself right
almost like chemo radiation purging a
lot of unnecessary BS layoffs at all
these companies only essential functions
and then maybe one I know that
everything ultimately is bad yeah but
there could be one benefit that in the
end more essential businesses rise up
and we get rid of a lot of his
non-essential wasted space that was
actually causing us problems and hurting
us okay so that's a maybe yeah I don't
know for sure it see I can see the
parallels thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you